nice back
and so much of his previous seasons have
been about training harder or I have to
run faster but he's up against a villain
this season that he can't outrun it's
somebody that he has to out think yeah
and it's gonna take him and Cisco and
Caitlin and a few other surprise people
to be able to get one step ahead of the
finger hey everybody the flash is back
and we have a mystery to decode so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video
well announce a new winner later in the
video but the big thing here we need to
talk about are the mystery symbols the
speedforce language that Barry comes out
not fully understanding but just writing
down like a crazy person with that beard
of his so a lot of you might be familiar
with movies like a rival or with agents
of shield that both had mystery
languages mystery symbols that people
had to decode to unlock this great power
or unlock a map that gave them access to
power like on agents of shield it was
giving them access to the Terrigen mists
it was a much bigger concept during
arrival so just remember that you know
decoding the symbols gives him ultimate
power but it's the fundamental MacGuffin
of the season so you come out of the
Speed Force you don't even know who the
villain is but you know that there's
this mystery language that you have to
decode that has the sum total of all the
knowledge that the Speed Force has given
to Barry like the knowledge of the
universe is in his head he just doesn't
understand it and it's gonna take all
season long for him to figure it out but
once he does he'll be the ultimate
version of the flash so you can already
guess that if it's gonna take him all
season to figure this out then it's
probably going to have something to do
with how he defeats the thinker now
remember Sabbat are did tease us with
the solution to that he said the neural
inhibitor cap and there's no reason to
think he was lying about that this is
where we came up with the Cerebral
inhibitor to use against the bow
he was one of those people that would
dangle the truth in front of you or try
to use the truth to hurt you he didn't
lie about too many big things and it was
sort of confirmed by abracadabra
the thinker would be a big villain we
defeated him with a neural inhibitor cap
which sounds an awful lot like versions
of the comic book solution so the really
cool thing you may have already picked
up on this the idea that there's gonna
be this ongoing mystery and it'll have
something to do with the way that he
defeats the thinker unlocking all these
crazy powers that he doesn't know that
he has yet we've gotten a version of
that every single season there's always
some MacGuffin that pushes us forward
there's always a version of a bunch of
formulas on the blackboard or on one of
the boards behind them like some
complicated plan they're trying to
figure out that takes them all season
long what are the number of different
things that we can change about the
future to save iris you go back to
season 2 season 1 it was all about the
speed formula like they even had the
special speed formula from the comics
amongst other ways that Barry could get
faster maybe we've been going about
improving my speed the wrong way I've
been learning different techniques
involved in running and I was thinking
that there's just as much science
involved in speed as anything physical
or technical I just can't figure out how
to apply it to me when I run thought if
anybody could help me interview this is
quite the speed equation you've
concocted here isn't it Mr Al yeah I've
been doing a lot of reading down time
because like they said during the promo
the makeup and back then was all about
just getting faster training harder to
be a better runner and now he needs to
train to be a better thinker how do you
train someone to be a better thinker you
give them the biggest brain teaser you
could possibly imagine and that's what
the Speed Force has given him it's given
him this giant puzzle to solve and in
thinking through that it will help him
out think the thinker but I think the
real idea here though is that you have
no idea what the Speed Force considers
to be ultimate power so during the
arrival movie they have this language
they needed to code so that they can
communicate with aliens it hold this
global catastrophe but once amy adams
decodes the language
she finds out that she actually can see
through time she starts getting
flashbacks but the language itself is
actually a formula for time travel it
allows people to exist the way that the
aliens do in the cool thing about the
aliens in that movie is that there are a
lot like the speedforce wormhole aliens
and then they exist beyond space time so
that's how you time travel when you
exist beyond space time you sort of
exist in the past present and future
simultaneously so that's what Barry's
life was like when he was in the Speed
Force he which is experiencing all of
time simultaneously which is why Grant
Gustin made those comments about how he
experienced multiple lifetimes while he
was in there but now that he's back on
Team flash in the third dimension
he just doesn't experience reality the
same way he did when he was experiencing
past present and future at the same time
so thus the mystery so the idea is is
that he will get faster but not in the
way that you would think like not
literally running across the ground
faster his mind will get faster he'll
exist on a higher level now we've seen a
version of that in previous seasons like
he has that short-term memory retention
for a half-hour he could become the
smartest man on earth for about 30
minutes at a time then it's all gone the
thinker's mind become so powerful in the
comics that he's like that all the time
though so the flash needs to decode
these symbols so that he can rise to the
level of the Speed Force wormhole aliens
and challenge the thinker now I think
the whole idea of the season is it the
thinker will debut and he'll also get
powered up throughout the season usually
it's that thing where the villain starts
out with a lot of power but they also
become more powerful as things go along
so I've already done a couple thinker
videos and they haven't completely
explained what the TV show version is
gonna start out like but in the comics
he doesn't automatically start out as
smart as he is when he's at his full
power so what will happen is is when we
get to episode 1 we'll actually get a
much better shot with sharper images of
those symbols so we can start picking
through those but we're meant to learn
about that through the course of the
season so don't be surprised if it takes
you a couple episodes to figure out
what's going on
but again just remember the arrival
movie is not like they're just decoding
instructions it's like once you unlock
the instructions you also experience
reality on a higher
plane of existence so the fastest man in
the world will also develop the fastest
mind in the world so let me know in the
comments what do you think is going on
with the symbols do you think that it
will just help him unlock those
abilities or do you think that there's
something else to it as well because the
way those are grouped it looks like
there are a lot of formulas built in
there but the symbols don't seem to have
any pattern at this point and they don't
look like anything from the comics so it
does look like an original creation of
the TV show like usually when you see a
lot of formulas in the comics they're
just legit math formulas like you saw
back during the first couple of seasons
when they were trying to work out
Barry's speed Geoff Johns did some
interesting things with the Flash's
powers when he was fighting the thinker
it was the wally west version of the
flash but it's the same idea it's like
him unlocking Super Saiyan God mode like
you unlock Super Saiyan mode but then
you go a level beyond that and unlock
god mode if you guys are big Dragon Ball
fans but if you're not don't worry it's
just him existing on a higher plane so
your mind and your body become faster
you exist more because you're so full of
Speed Force but if there was any
confusion he does come right out of the
Speed Force in the first episode way
Bastyr than when he went in so he's
already more powerful than he was before
and they actually just showed off a
better look at the new flash suit this
is what its gonna look like when it's on
the pedestal so it seemingly confirms
that they're gonna shred the old suit
when Wally tries to wear it and go up
against the Sam erodes but what'll
happen is is there'll be some new promos
they'll probably drop in the next couple
weeks especially for the other TV shows
too so just leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below I'll
say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Eddie the Martian please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details if there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post DC while you wait for
everything click here to watch that
flash trailer again and you can click
here for the arrow season 6 Deathstroke
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight